[Music]
first ever quarantine cast I've got here
with me Nico hi everybody
oh hello there and we've got Christian
via audio only loop because his camera
was breaking right before we started to
film this but here we all are yo what's
up y'all
Christian has been using a really nice
microphone - so he sounds like he's
actually in a podcast studio no it's
like a Marantz all-in-one camera and mic
tower thing into one thing but yeah the
camera is freaking out right now
yeah welcome home boys day 6 of
quarantine yeah yeah if you hear a baby
in the background this time I know we'd
started warranty on Wednesday so only
five are you an index zero index on the
weekend I guess so seven seven counting
the weekend see yeah yeah I feel like
I'm working more do you guys feel like
that yeah I'm with you Jake it's harder
to like put invest myself into like the
right mentality to get work done
sometimes okay so you're one of those
discover that there's two kinds of
people when it comes to working from
home ah so far this week the people who
are like it's harder for me to get stuff
done because I need that physical space
that I go to that I'm used to doing work
at mm-hmm and then there's also the
people that are like no I get more done
now because I never leave work it's
always with me
Clint's one of those guys she's getting
more done now than if he was at the
studio cuz he's like he likes his N Out
and like put on his like ambient music
and like it really invested into
something so yeah yeah I'd say I'm a mix
because I still need that place to work
so
we actually have like this separated
wall that opens up in my den so I do
have like my office though that I can go
and just plug in but it's at my house
then obviously step into the living room
and kind of get that break it's nice and
stuff yeah my living room okay - cool
reloads if you guys don't recognize it
from tactical do you recognize it now
you a nice little battle station set out
there they got those RGB keyboards to
make you type fast yeah I actually just
picked that one up it's wireless - oh
really
wireless mouse - I'm assuming oh yeah
very cool yeah it's the only way to go
[Music]
Wow so Ren what type of person are you
are you getting more or less done right
now certainly a lot less I am not
adjusting well just keep staring in the
background at that one wheel behind me
it took a lot of effort to like kind of
like clean out my spot here and get like
I had to go get my work computer cuz my
my home computer just wasn't cutting it
and then setting all that up took a long
time so yeah it's been a little hard for
me to adjust but I'm at a point now
where I'm back up to a hundred percent
productivity yeah
I'm actually really impressed at how
fast everyone sort of figured out their
own modus operandi mmm I expected it to
take a lot longer I'll be honest but I
feel like we only need lost like I don't
know maybe a day of work I make it like
two and a half but either way we know
pudding
delivering cuts you know yeah I think
have yet to miss a single Saturday of a
react episode that's true a year that
we've been doing it even in spite of a
pandemic forcing us into our own homes
speaking of which why we're all doing
this in the first place yeah so yes it's
pretty crazy how everybody's reacting to
it differently across the country
because right now in New York you have
five percent of the entire world's cases
in the in New York right now
of kovat 19 and I part of it I think
it's because they've actually been
actively testing everybody so they have
actually a pretty good handle on
everyone who actually has it a good rule
of thumb so if you're looking at numbers
you're right
a good rule of thumb is that the death
rate is 1% of the infection rate
realistically it's probably even a
little bit lower than 1% but if somebody
reports having a hundred deaths and they
only have a thousand cases that tells
you that there's actually 9,000
undocumented cases running around you
know so that's like when things like
you'll see states that report like oh we
have 50 deaths and we only of a thousand
documented cases and that's a sign that
there are so many thousands of people
that have corona virus that haven't been
tested in those states so I think how
many how many people do you think that
is like just just just rough guess based
on what you've seen so far like how many
people have have it and have been
documented and recorded as having it how
many people actually have it so right
now in the United States there's 53,000
documented cases and there's 684 deaths
now granted those cases having us run
their course but overall in the United
States total we're we're getting closer
and closer like if you just go by the
numbers we should probably be at about
75,000 cases for 684 deaths if not more
cases you know like so if you look at
New York they have twenty five thousand
six hundred cases as of this moment and
210 total deaths
so they're at about that one percent
that we're talking about but if you look
at I'm on we're
dah meters calm winds there's 650 people
that have died and there's and we're
estimating there's 75,000 cases
yeah I'd say in the United States you're
talking about 0.85 percent yes
mortality rate is the death still that's
numbers higher than flu it's way higher
the flu is below 0.1% yeah well yeah I
guess the flus been around for so long
that we've got pretty good information
on that yeah so the doubling rates is
every 2 days yes
like almost exactly every infected
person with co19 on average infects two
and a half more people are now and as
long as that number stays above one you
will continuously see an exponential
growth but real quick
Michigan for example has 1,700
documented cases and they have total
deaths of 24 so they're actually they're
a little bit under reporting but
Washington Washington is a big one so
Washington right now only has 2,000
documented cases and a hundred and ten
deaths so what does that tell you about
how many cases are actually in
Washington right now you know yeah
there's gotta be way more yeah
and that's just because we haven't
ramped up testing but already people
aren't taking it seriously like you go
out in a hundred Street and like half
the businesses still have people coming
and going and it's just like it's
worrying it's really worrying it seems
like you know this this whole discussion
of Liberty right like we are a free
country we don't have a dictator that
can just come and tell you where to stay
in their house but with that privilege
of that freedom in that self
I guess responsibility comes with comes
that comes with the responsibility of
being informed and making the right call
at the right time and so many people
have shuffled off that responsibility of
being informed and you know having some
sense and civic duty and just to have
entirely invested themselves like well
whatever it's not going to affect me so
I'm gonna go do whatever I want I just I
firstly find that very very frustrating
and I know there's a balance between
like you know the economic impact of
this versus like the death toll but
right now when you're in like the first
week or two weeks of this it's like now
is not the time to be like well it's
just too inconvenient for me so I don't
know
I have a lot of thoughts on this yeah I
don't disagree generally I do think yeah
there is a you're right with that with
that freedom comes the responsibility to
know what to do and when to do it and to
keep yourself informed that's how that's
how a vibrant democracy works so there's
that people can't but you know there's
always gonna be the idiots out there or
just like well it's not gonna affect me
so whatever and that's obviously not the
right way to go about it but but you're
right there is this looming economic
storm that has very quickly create been
created from this like really yeah this
has also been a really interesting case
study in denial you know it's like every
single person in the world right now is
coming to terms with this at different
rates like some people are looking at
the math and accepting it before anyone
else has even heard of the virus other
people are hearing all these studies and
or uh you know all the news and whatnot
and they just straight-up don't believe
it two opposite ends of the spectrum
there and everyone else is within that
spectrum somewhere and you know like I
have I have friends who are like well
not a big deal like it'll be it'll it's
not going to be that big of a thing but
the entire theme of all of this is that
it continues to be a bigger thing than
everyone guessed it would be so it's
like yeah well if one if less them say
say it say that say the assumption is
like 0.75 percent of people that get it
die mm-hmm well there's 350 million
people that live in the United States so
you're talking about 3.2 million people
it's a lot of people caveat to that yeah
and that is the assumption that the
health care system hasn't collapsed yeah
you only hit the 0.7 percent when you
have enough hospital beds and
ventilators for people because with us
cessful e flattening the curve as they
said if we don't flatten the curve in
the you know they're starting to have to
decide who lives and who dies more and
more people are gonna die it's like
that's why yes what are you to the three
to four percent which is happening in
Italy you know that's that's when
thirty-year-olds I'm twenty year olds
died of pneumonia because if you don't
have if you get pneumonia that can
that's that's deadly
we just take it for granted in this day
and age that's something that you can
cure with some antibiotics and you know
you go to the hospital can you do it
like we've totally taken that for
granted because we've all honestly it's
been pretty lucky to live in the society
that we live in and then suddenly
imagine hospitals disappearing not just
for you but for everyone if you get in a
car accident you're screwed you get a
heart attack you're screwed you get sick
you're screwed
like nobody gets to go to the hospital
like that's what you're looking at yeah
and you can't get those antibiotics and
all those things you need to cure that
disease exactly right yeah so it would
have it would have this sort of offset
of like additional deaths and associated
incidents that that would cause
additional damage yeah everybody gets
sick at the same time if you let it grow
exponentially like if it if you don't
like I say flatten the curve right
either it was like the line that we're
trying to flatten the curve underneath
is also variable in and of itself and
there's the whole point of mutation but
we'll get to that in a second how do you
how do you flatten well so remember I
said on average two and a half feet will
get infected for each person that gets
coronavirus what you need to do is you
need to get that value below one that's
how you flatten the curve so when that
value is above one but the curve becomes
sharper and sharper and sharper and that
value is below one the curve becomes
flatter and flatter and flatter so what
we need to have happen is for everybody
that gets coronavirus they need to
infect less than one person on average
to get that curve to flatten and the
only way for that to happen is for
people to stop getting each other's sick
and you can stop giving each other sick
by stopping going out and talking to
random people coughing or even people
shaking hands with random people giving
hugs everything
strangers it does is there is the actual
actual problem that people that are
showing symptoms aren't staying at home
well so that's that's a hard thing is
you don't show symptoms for the first
like four days to five days you have
this are you are you infecting people
yes you're contagious at that point so
you're shedding the virus for those
first four to five days to everybody
that's usually upwards of ten that's
true and some people don't show any
symptoms so for the entire run of the
infection Milo's freaking out over these
facts the entire run of the infection
you're contagious and you don't even
know that you have it and so for those
ten days or 14 days you've just been you
know looking your hands and touching
everybody yeah it's pretty crazy so
what's the idea behind this kind of
two-week period how does this help stop
things cuz obviously as we get later we
have to talk about like how long are
people really supposed to stay close but
what is this initial two-week period
yeah so the idea is that if you know for
a fact if you have a few different
controls if for instance if you know
that you have not interacted with a
single person or a single object outside
of your vicinity and you've been in
quarantine for ten days you know for a
fact that you are not sick and so all of
this this two-week thing this three-week
thing is just to weed out to identify
everyone who's not sick and is already
sick it's yeah it's just you're trying
to find who's already sick so you can
like laser focus on them to be
completely quarantined and then when
let's say you have a group of friends
and every single one of you managed to
be in complete isolation reasonably so
for you know ten days or more than you
know
that all of you are not sick and now you
can hang out with each other as long as
you are not still forgetting me anyone
else it's like it's it's a very it
becomes a very exclusive club where you
know if you and your I hear you sorry my
computer just like completely crashed on
me for a moment
yes if you and your friend have both
been a in isolation for long enough you
can now hang out with each other because
you're you're reasonably reliably not
sick both know that but you have to
maintain the social isolation from
everyone else
so because someone else can still get
you sick that's where it's a little bit
of a challenge for me because Jenna
could be sick at any moment so if you do
have it you will eventually show
symptoms with after or within that
two-week period yeah no there's no not
feeling symptoms at all but still having
it in contracting it there's I mean like
half of cases I don't even know the
exact number but most cases are mild so
you might not realize you're showing
symptoms but you are so that's so that's
so that's the thing so I'm saying after
the two weeks say I you know maybe
they're minor and I don't think it's any
more than just a slightly runny nose and
but I don't feel sick at all but you
know two weeks is up and I'm still
feeling fine I'm then I mean yeah so I
guess I guess even past the TV period at
any point I can get infected and then
infect more people so how not we keep up
this quarantine thing or in that kind of
stuff you know like even after the TUI
period how do we continue going on about
daily life that daily life is on hold
for a very long time that's the
unfortunate truth
you know we're sweet like if everyone
it's like playing the perfect game of
telephone you know when like you say
information to someone's ear and then
they transfer all that information you
go down the line
and if what the person at the end yes
you know the thing about that thing is
that that game never works the end of
the line always has something different
but assuming you could get something
perfect out of that and comparing that
to say like everyone in isolation you
can now say that you're not sick but you
still have to maintain strict discipline
of not going out to crowded areas you
know you still have to be isolated from
everyone else gotcha so then so what
you're saying is after this two-week
period
no one from corridor gets sick or show
symptom
we're good with Indian we say we resume
work we still kind of have to basically
keep the sort of listening distancing
and also trust that each other is not
you know going to the all those third
party possibilities of getting infected
and yeah so even if we do decide to go
back to work after this two week period
and everybody feels clear we have to
basically skill still keep this limited
within our group yeah go to raves share
drinks the same thing but actually
another big important thing too is that
the ideas of these two weeks by the
leadership hopefully in the healthcare
system time to get the testing set up
and start doing you know aggressive
tracing of people that have it and who
they've come into contact with
because right now South Korea doesn't
have things shut down South Korea still
has functioning restaurants and a public
transportation system like life's normal
in South Korea and they were hit you
know just like we were but what they did
to get over it was a really extensive
testing they tested everybody so they
forgot who had it and who didn't and the
people who then had it like they very
extensively traced everybody that came
into contact with which honestly people
in America probably are gonna get kind
of iffy about you know like we're pretty
anti-authority out here but like yeah
yeah it's the hardest part but can you
know it's like can we deal with that can
we like stop being babies for a moment
okay and like deal with the real problem
after that yeah note that Korea jumped
on it immediately yeah that's what I'm
saying so because they did that they're
actually on the the curve back up I
guess and now they're back open and
things are kind of moving mm-hmm I think
yeah this is bigger than a lot of people
think it is yeah a lot of ways it's not
just necessarily in like the whole
mortality rate which obviously has its
own risk factors but there's couple
other things going on here one it's a
huge test of our economy and whether our
government is capable of creating an
adequate
response to like people employed not
necessarily like by the government and
obviously but but the government
propping up the businesses that have to
take hits yeah because of this
undoubtedly
and then secondarily like a test of your
individual autonomy in a democracy such
as the United States where you we're not
gonna have the government and go
probably a knock on every door say your
lock down your lock down your lock down
because that's not how we function but
at the same time you're right Nico it's
on the sovereignty of each individual to
be like hey what's my responsibility in
this yeah and if we can all do that then
supply chains can stay in effect
businesses can get through this and then
everyone can move on with their lives
but all of those things have to function
together one one thing that I have
noticed is have you noticed how nobody
is talking about petty things anymore on
the internet that's true yeah like that
has just gone away oh did you guys hear
how apparently the the tape that Kim
Kardashian leaked about Taylor Swift was
actually a lie tell the truth that seems
just so I mean I yeah that seems to me
like so uncouth at the moment yeah yes
people are realizing that that stuff's
not really important I mean we're all
dealing with the virus now worldwide so
things like a Kardashian headline is
less important about getting some
information about how we get through
this realizing it could happen it I mean
that's one of the funniest things like
the mental leaves that people go through
it's like everybody's told you know you
should have an emergency fund you know I
know it I already can afford one so I'm
not speaking to the people that are you
know in that situation but if you're
making money even make
money for you know a couple years I knew
you've set aside a little bit to just
have some savings you know and the
pledges you should have an emergency
fund because at some point your life you
might have an emergency might be out of
work for two or three weeks and a lot
yeah I don't need one of those I won't
get hit with an emergency and then we
everyone got here with an emergency the
entire world got hit with an emergency
and people are still now going in was
like yeah but I probably won't get sick
it's like you just got hit with that
emergency that you thought would never
happen to you and now you're still
applying this mentality of like yeah but
it still probably won't happen to me
it's like but it just happened to you
like things happen life happens you need
be a little bit prepared for the
potholes because life isn't always
smooth that statement cuz now okay like
what's your what's your responsibility
as well an employer right two people
yeah I mean I believe your
responsibility as an employer is to help
your employees get through something
like this like well for one ideally the
leadership and then the people that can
help with something like this and this
is tricky because I don't like talking
about stuff that's in other people's
hands when it comes like you know issues
you know think about what I can do but
like ideally the leadership takes this
time to get ready to then solve the
problem once every is done with
self-isolation yeah like yeah we can
continue access for the rich
corporations like we can continue you
know let's say corridor resumes in two
weeks right you know we can go to
corridor we can make a point of you know
keeping our distance washing our hands
wear your masks you know if you're gonna
if you feel anything at all wear masks
etc you know it's like be responsible
don't go to big groups etc like we can
take those steps and with those steps we
will continue to mitigate to that curve
that exponential growth but like I
believe your job as an employer is to
you know ideally help people through
this like yeah you could make a buck by
laying off your employees for two weeks
and then rehiring everybody but that's
unless your business is literally on
that verge of failing where your cash
flow can't handle a two week bump which
once again you're still in the same
situation as anybody else who doesn't
have any emergency funds so that's an
irresponsible business owner you should
do the right thing and not try to make
it that
to buck here yeah sure people might not
be coming in for like two weeks here but
like don't throw them out in the street
but this comes down that whole civic
duty again it's like once again we're
not in a dictatorship because we believe
that our that individuals in this
country should have the knowledge and
the intelligence and the education not
just [ __ ] on each other you know and
like help each other out when it matters
and have a civic duty when it matters
like we have this belief that people
have have that amount of responsibility
I believe it's true I believe people can
pull that off otherwise you know mankind
would have never made it through one of
the hundreds of you know very
threatening things we've been and you
know everything from the world wars to
various depressions you know all that
kind of stuff you know people do I
believe band together but you know I
guess we haven't really been faced with
a crisis since maybe 2008 and even then
I'd argue that 2008 it's not as big of a
crisis as people talk about it as like
it as an economic issue as an economic
crisis but it's nothing like a world war
you know you didn't have millions of
people dying it's been a long time since
like as as a whole you know our our
population has had to face a real crisis
that requires all all millions of us all
300 million of us here in America for
example to band together and do
something about it
and because that you've had people that
you know that's that's when people
started complaining about Kim Kardashian
because I have a I have a core belief
that people need a cause and when there
isn't really any baddie to fight there's
no enemy to crush like people start
looking for something they need
something to fight and be outraged about
that's why you have so much outrage
culture on the internet right now is
because shit's good or was good you know
it's like yeah life's good that's that's
not just a belief that's that's a that's
a truth man like that's people we've
evolved to create our little pockets and
to be be unified in his pockets and and
to move forward that's how we've evolved
like mentally and and physically and
biologically and socially so that's
absolutely true the thing that I think
is interesting as well to go off one of
the things you were saying is like yeah
you you could make a buck
in the short-term if you're a kind of
business and you can say okay guys no
one's going to get paid for X amount of
time and you know we have the luxury of
being an online business primarily so
we're not gonna be as hard hit
immediately by this as like say a
physical manufacturing non-essential
business right but like even if you
think that you're winning in the short
term if everybody else does that and
then all the sudden there's layoffs and
then all this like that eventually comes
back around you because the economy is
an ecosystem yeah and if and if one part
of the ecosystem is affected it'll
affect to others and so on and so forth
until it gets back around to you and I
have no doubt that even though in a time
where more people are staying home even
beyond the initial like self equation
quarantine thing we're still gonna see
we're still gonna see a hit probably an
Adsense and things like that because now
companies that were out there spending
money are not out there spending money
anymore
and eventually that's going to come
around to us as well and I think it's
we're probably on like a at least a
quarterly delay on that you know ad
money's spent quarterly but still I I
feel like that's gonna happen and
hopefully viewership will go up a little
bit because more people are staying at
home and that'll offset some of the loss
and Adsense but at the same time you
know like yeah you have to think about
this as in like you know if your
neighbor is working for an airline
company and an airline company goes
under that that's gonna affect you know
third point they might not affect you
tomorrow
but in a few weeks in a few months it
will yeah definitely I mean being you
know I guess I've always tried to
knowing that corridor is like a public
facing company where you know we have
cameras in our office and you know
recording stuff that we do like I've
always tried to at least
the example for how I hope other people
would run their business you know just
trying to be public with it you know
like this is what we do like well we'll
make the changes we'll make the
adjustments and yeah it's obviously it's
easier for us to work from home than say
somebody who works in McDonald's again
make McDonald's burgers from home but
like at the same time it obviously be
easier for us to be in the office
filming with each other like we're not
in the podcast studio right now
recording this no he had to spend the
half-hour doing all the tech
troubleshooting to get this up and
running that we don't have to spend if
we would have just done this in the
studio yeah so how do you feel about
companies like Walmart McDonald's who do
not have paid sick leave I mean I think
it's crappy I think it's not treating
people correctly I think there's a
balance obviously with everything like
there is a cash flow for these
restaurants fast food places make a
certain amount of money every month and
so on so forth and obviously if your
expenses are more than your income then
you go bankrupt and that's the end of
that in goodbye to your business like so
there's obviously a balance but like now
at least here at corridor we try to have
you know a certain amount of runway so
it's for some reason all add money to
stop coming in we'd have a little period
of time here to like figure something
out and that's that's responsible
business ownership you know it's a and
yes not every business has that luxury I
totally get that once again I'm not
talking about the exceptions I'm not
talking about the small isolated cases
I'm talking about general you know
workflow general business general
lifestyle etc so yeah it's but so it
will be I mean it's gonna be on the
government at some point to come up with
some sort of stimulus for this yeah what
else you do they're really the only
entity that's existent at least in our
society that can that can prop something
up like this I was listening to a guy on
CNBC this morning and he was talking
about how he thinks that this is gonna
be a ten trillion dollar bridge to the
other side I don't know I mean that
might be a little sensationalism but who
knows like it just comes down to people
like you and me you know all of us here
people listen
this it comes down to whether or not we
can stop the virus from spreading like
and we people have done it
other countries have done it South
Korea's already done it they've fixed it
they're done like they got through it
without having to spend ten trillion
dollars so are we are we smart enough to
do this without spending ten million
dollars ten trillion dollars or are we
go that comparison though Neko is that
because I mentioned earlier like they
got on to it like right away when they
only had like a few hundred cases they
were already shutting things down
same with Japan you know they shut down
their schools like immediately
we went six and a half seven weeks
before making any sort of action and in
that time it was doubling every two days
and it's like they're even now that we
are like starting to like you know take
these measures to like stop the spread
its there's already going to be in an
economic impact just because of what the
the time that it took for us to take
action true I don't think about the ten
trillion dollar mark yet you know and
honestly I don't think we're at the like
two trillion dollar mark yet it comes
down to what happens in the next month
in two weeks like two weeks of
everything just stopping that's not the
end of the world we like people can
start up again from two weeks three
months of everything stopping that gets
pretty messy you know and obviously in
between there's a gradient
but like that's the thing is at least
right now it's not the time to be like
oh I can't do it it's like we're gonna
be doing this more for more than five
days like we're only five days into like
our you know or six days into our
quarantine like it's gonna be hard it's
gonna take time but if you do it now
it's better than doing it later so you
know short term this is long-term
rewards and everything we go back though
like even when we go back to working in
groups and stuff we're gonna have to be
maintaining still the same protocols
like right now you know at home we're
only going to like you know when he
known at the grocery store and she's
getting what she needs and then she's
where she's coming back and we're
leaving the kids here and stuff and just
kind of one person at a time
mm-hmm that's gonna have to probably go
on for months I think yeah once again it
just it comes down to is do we have
enough
Ericka's of rich country like are we
going to put our resources into having
people doing lots of testing and tracing
down people who have been who have it
and who they've been exposed to and
finding those people and you know asking
them to be in quarantine you know one of
the things I do in Singapore that they
did before the corona virus outbreak is
sometimes in certain buildings they
would take your temperature
you'd walk inside and you'd have a dude
with like a little thermometer with like
one of those like you know replaceable
ear things and they'd take your
temperature and if you showed that you
had a fever like for any reason you
couldn't go into the building and that's
like that's an example of one of the
things here that you could implement to
keep people safe and get through this
but are people gonna pull it up with a
two-second inconvenience Oh having
somebody put something in your ear like
I don't know some people won't and it's
disappointing that that's the case but
that's what happens when you don't
really have any sort of thing like this
ever have happened before to bond people
together and establish it in your
culture which is what has happened and
you know Japan and South Korea and all
that kind of stuff so we know we'll
probably pay the price of million people
dead and we'll figure it out from there
because that's just kind of how human
beings work that's a little pessimistic
[Music]
right now giving every American a
thousand dollars I mean that's it's a
decent way to get through some of this
but like you know it's in conjunction
with the companies that also make
billions of dollars they should be doing
their part and also supporting people
let's you know I think people misplace a
little bit responsibility on the federal
government like why isn't the president
doing anything about this it's like well
the president isn't in charge of your
city and he's not in charge of your
state because that's just how the US
government is structured it's on your
your city's government and your States
government - honestly deal with this and
we have 50 different states we're going
to all handle it slightly different ways
and the federal government certainly
plays a part in it but like even just
leadership of you know if you have
health insurance
who's your health insurance provider
like where's their leadership in this
where why are they not sending you
emails saying this is what this is where
you go to get tested because they're the
companies that should be handling this
and it's just as much like don't just
blame the president because he's a
reality TV show guy that's easy to hate
look to the people that should be in
charge of these things and expect them
to step up to the plate your health
insurance company should be stepping up
to the plate you know your doctor's
office needs to step up to the plate and
they usually do but like that's their
the health professionals you need to
look to them companies like Walmart if
they employ millions of people they need
to step up to the plate too they can't
just fire everybody and let it be
somebody else's problem these companies
all have social responsibilities
everybody has social responsibilities I
do you do like we all do as individuals
in a society we have social
responsibilities so yeah you know it's
gotta be something where people make the
sacrifices and come together to get
through something like this and the
better we handle it now though the less
the impact is so yeah a week is gonna be
April 1st and that'll be rinsed day for
everyone yes for so many people who have
been unable to make money over the last
couple weeks they're not gonna be able
to pay rent so another idea to help kind
of solve or not solve but to help
mitigate part of the crisis is to enact
a rent freeze mm-hmm where no one has to
pay rent corporations or people just no
rents is transacted how do you guys feel
about that idea so how does that affect
the landlord's in the building opener oh
you know I'm owners and things like that
so that's affecting them right I mean
there's a couple things to unpack there
the first first there's the there's the
individual level and then there's the
then there's the business and real
estate level and so first foremost like
the the the individual stimulus right
that that could be functional for a
short term as in like here's something
right now - just stop gap an immediate
short-term problem but that giving peace
giving people money solution isn't a
long-term solution I don't think by any
stretch because what you what the
foundation of wealth and success is
creating opportunities that people
engage with that then they get money in
exchange for that and they participate
in those things
and so eventually you don't want the
businesses to fail because the
businesses are the actual foundation of
self sovereignty and the the money that
you need to to have that sovereignty so
I think you could do something in the
short term that's like hey guys
everybody gets you know people people
who need to get X amount of dollars
right now but if you just if that's the
policy going forward in the long term I
don't think that's realistic at all
because eventually who's gonna who's
gonna pay that back people that work at
businesses and businesses are gonna pay
that back that money's gonna come back
to the American Treasury through taxes
which come through jobs which is going
to come through individuals and
corporations and small businesses that
are gonna pay those taxes so the the
bedrock of that is that you need the you
you can't let that many businesses fail
and so and the sort of underlying thing
underneath that is real estate like
because real estate is the final sort of
bedrock of the of the economy in a way
because everybody still needs to live
somewhere and you cannot avoid that no
matter what you do or where you go or
how you do it so yeah I think you kind
of need to take it in stepped and like
address the worst problems first right
you have like self quarantine and if you
need to talk about an individual
stimulus okay but the the longer-term
solution is making sure that that
businesses aren't failing at a massive
rate both big and small and yeah so
here's a slightly different question
then let's say if one of those policies
was to go into effect for only one month
let's say the month of April which is
the better option
everyone gets $1,000 or no one has to
pay rent that's a good question there's
a kind of the same thing to be honest
everyone has different amounts of rent
everyone has different expenses true but
in the big like the big scheme of things
you know whether somebody pays $1,500
some pays $500 like it still kind of
comes out it kind of comes out to be the
same thing but really what it boils down
to is
you know we're all frozen for a month
and can we any go oh I can hear I okay
sorry basically yeah always getting at
is I I think the effect either of those
would have is the same I think I think
giving people a bailout for a month is a
good idea you don't know what I actually
would do I would do this if you test
positive for the coronavirus and you
voluntarily quarantine yourself in
facility for quarantine you get paid
that's what I would do I would pay
people who are sick to come in and
quarantine themselves for two weeks
rather than like an advises people to
get sick it's okay I don't care like
step one right where we're in the step
one phase like people people want to get
sick later fine we'd like deal with like
take it away then but like right now
when people are spreading it there's no
social isolation like so this is one of
the things they dealt with like in China
they penalize people for breaking curfew
and for like you know breaking
quarantine and the fine was $1000 they
went wait a minute let's just give them
a thousand dollars if they voluntarily
stay in quarantine for two weeks instead
and that totally helped like a totally
switched how things worked and like
people instead of prisoners people going
in voluntarily and they're getting
tested even when they're not feeling
symptoms just in the hopes that yeah
they're gonna get paid yeah it also
requires proper distribution of testing
right now we're not close to that I mean
these are all issues 100% but like it's
just that's one way you can help
incentivize the social isolation in the
quarantine to happen because everybody's
saying but my job I got a payment I got
pay my rent and it's like yes you do
have to pay rent and yes you do have
your job also we don't to kill people
and there is a balance but right now the
balance should be a little bit more
heavily and don't kill people um but at
least in terms of that like there's a
way to like hey here's a reason to
isolate and not going to work if you're
sick because he'll you can get you know
your thousand or 2,000 bucks and yeah
like the 1% of people that are scumbags
will try to get sick again
you know or try to get the coronavirus
so they can get paid a thousand bucks
but you know what if you're that
desperate maybe it's for the better that
you just go in there and you know it's
like that's once again it's an isolated
case but I do think you know I do think
giving people and individuals something
to get them through this say it's
whether it's a rent freeze or you know a
stipend or whatever it is I I'd lean
towards giving people the money rather
than freezing rent the other thing
freezing rent would be easier to
implement no I don't because there's a
whole lot of different ways that happens
if I give you a check for $1,000 it's a
check for $1,000 you know flat that's it
you know it's it's very easy to
interpret that it's $1,000 versus like
it's a freeze on rent will set a freeze
on mortgage will actually had a deal
with this guy rent was like this I pay
rent every two months not one month so I
get one month off like I pay $5,000 in
rent I pay $1,000 in rent I pay $200 and
rent like it's all over the place for
the rent freeze thing and there's the
fact that all goes through banks
eventually yeah and obviously right now
I think you're avoiding like the the
option of giving the big corporations
the money but all that money goes back
to those big corporations in the bank in
the memory has to pay rent either so
might as well help those people as well
you know what about the people that have
their house paid off but they're still
obviously having to pay the property
taxes and make other ends meet you know
they're in financial trouble too
so I think I think the first step is you
know the ballot is good but like the
other thing too is that when you start
messing with the economy and you start
artificially inflating or deflating
certain parts of the economy or
manipulating supply and demand you very
quickly end up breaking stuff and it's
one thing to give everybody that money
bump in their account to get them
through a lurch it's another thing to
start telling people like you can't
collect checks and you can't collect
checks but you can collect checks but
you can't collect checks you guys are in
a gray area we don't have enough
bureaucracy to deal with you guys yet so
you're in a line we'll talk to you in a
month like that's when you start
breaking the whole economy around real
estate and rental and all that kind of
stuff versus just like I said running
cheque
and deal with it in a couple weeks
appear out the next step yeah it's yeah
it's like you gotta also look at like
what is the government good at and what
is the government bad at and certainly
like they're a lot better at at writing
checks in a very mass-produced
like isolating and and individualizing
like corporations and trying to manage
that when the corporation's have
literally been built to be efficient at
that and now there's an entity stepping
in and telling them to do it differently
nothing to mention there's there's a
freeze on evictions too so you know if
you couldn't pay a rent what's your
landlord going to do kick you like they
can't kick you out so and then like if
they do like you know and landlords are
businesses too so it's like what's here
in the middle of quarantine the corona
virus is running everywhere landlord
can't take other people in and show them
the apartment like you know it's like
yeah they're better off just eating it
for a month just like everybody else in
the frickin world has to and then you
can pick it up from where you left off
you know yeah I got a handful of friends
that have to put their move or their you
know next place on hold because no one's
shown places and it's yeah so all right
let's let's let's get in more into the
nitty-gritty all right all right so
there was a recent bill that was
proposed that failed that apparently
correct me if I'm wrong here but
apparently this bill was attempting to
create you know I think it was something
like two trillion dollars of stimulus so
already we're at that two to two million
mark yeah so that never gets laid out a
little bit by the press a little bit
because a lot of that money is just the
government offering like so the
government like buys bonds back from
like that's issued all the time and this
is just them saying oh you usually we
only buy them back on these deadlines
but we'll just do it all now if you want
it in case you need the money if you're
holding one of these bonds we'll just
buy it back now and in reality we'd have
to wait like the two years but we'll
just do it now if you want and like
that's there that they're doing like
five hundred billion
like you know whatever it's a huge
amount of money of this but in reality
they do like 30 to 50 billion of that
every day
like that's just how the money flows so
they people like to throw that into the
headline to make it sound like you know
two trillion dollar stimulus package
when in reality it's not quite that you
know it's more nuanced than that but it
doesn't mean oh but regardless the the
basic core tenants if I understand them
correctly of this bill were to give
loans to small businesses then we
wouldn't have to pay those back and then
also give loans to the in big businesses
that would eventually have to pay those
back mm-hmm and that was that was shot
down yeah yeah I think they need be
careful with that you know it's really
easy to get taken advantage of as a
taxpayer in the United States because
you don't have people lobbying for you
and the government and so I think it's
it's the stimulus thing isn't something
needs to happen today the stimulus thing
can happen in a couple days it could
happen in a week it can happen in two
weeks honestly like it doesn't need to
happen immediately it's I think it's
more important to do that right because
the economic impact of it is gnarly
longer yeah yeah the important thing
right now is to stop the virus spreading
exponentially because literally if you
can slow the curve down a little bit
it's a difference like for example if it
let's say it's doubling every every two
days well if you had 40,000 cases in one
day and then two days later you're at
eighty thousand cases and let's say
you're already at capacity with the
forty thousand cases like that's now
forty thousand new people are sick and
can't go see the doctor that's a lot of
people that get sick in like a day or
two days but if you can if you can stem
that just even a day that's another day
before your hospitals go get overwhelmed
it's another day to get testing out
there it's another day to get things
figured out and like literally buying us
a day like it's super valuable and
you're doing with exponential increase
because the day makes all the difference
in the world the days that are between 1
million and two million people wants to
further down that curve like that's a
lot of people like the problem is you
get two numbers that are so big then
become abstracted like I mean I see
people arguing like oh you know 40,000
people died in car accidents each year
so it's another 40
you know today to this coronavirus it's
just like car accidents it's like that's
40,000 people like it's a big deal if
something 20 people at a freaking
nightclub like that's that's a horrible
like catastrophe and a reason saying you
know we need to you know take guns away
and all that kind of stuff like
everybody gets worked up about 30 people
getting shot but 40,000 people dying to
the coronavirus and people like that's
just like car accidents it's just like
the flu the flu kills 15,000 20,000
people every year
what's another 40,000 it's just like two
flus it's like it's weird it's weird how
people work it's you know once the
numbers get too big people that don't
realize yeah it's gonna people that
don't realize that they'll be old one
day yeah I mean my grandpa had to go to
the hospital yesterday for a
complication not related to the corona
virus and it was like is it gonna be
able to get the care he needs
fortunately they were able to perform
tests and get him out of the hospital
very quickly to reduce his exposure to
the hospital he's great he's fine so
hopefully we'll hear back in a day or
two what is wrong with him but yeah yeah
stop stop yeah I'm saying this is not a
good time to go to the hospital it might
not be the case I I heard you tell me
the other day that it sounds like the
exponential rate of cases is going down
is that where did you get that
so where did that what was that I've
been looking at world ah meters dot info
it tracks basically all the cases in the
world but specifically I've been looking
at the United States and of course
California and New York to some extent
because New York has a ton of cases
right now they've got 25,000 cases yeah
5,000 new ones today one fifth of the
entire cases were diagnosed today and
I'm sure by the time people
Podcast it's gonna be up another 10,000
tomorrow yeah so you know world honors a
day if you're listening so world honors
has graphs of different different things
and one of these graphs here is the
daily cases which let's see if my webcam
can adjust there you go
so you'll notice however and this might
be due to people becoming aware of the
virus which would be wonderful if this
is how how it's working you'll notice
that the number of cases today versus
yesterday not that big of a jump
now the Dave - the day before a huge
jump yeah yeah so it's been following
the exponential curve except for this
past day but it's just a day it's just
one data point it could be an outlier
just give it five because if you average
it out it's still exponential yeah it's
you know we know it's still going up we
know that much yeah yeah as long as our
the rate of infection is over one if
every person who gets the kronum virus
infects one point zero zero zero zero
zero one people you're still going to
hit an exponential curve it's just gonna
take a little while longer
it's still gonna spike up to a point
we're getting a million new cases a day
you need to get that rate below one it
needs to be even if it's point nine nine
nine it just needs to get below one and
your curve will stop being exponential
so I feel like as a person who lives in
a family group I feel like that's damn
near impossible if one of the people in
this house gets infected right so that's
the thing as one of the issues and what
they've solved this once again in South
Korea the issues here in America is that
people are where a sick have to stay
home and you end up getting your whole
family sick and that's not good whereas
if we had our [ __ ] together as a country
when you get sick you go to a place and
you spend your quarantine at a place
isolated from other people you know it's
one of the reasons why they're starting
to take over hotels and get them ready
for this kind of thing is because when
people get sick they need
not be at their house with the rest of
their family right now we're caught so
off-guard and no one's done any work on
this so if you get sick it's like uh go
home and hopefully you don't get the
rest of family sick but it's probably
gonna happen so all you guys just have
to deal with it and hopefully your
grandma doesn't die like that's what
we're looking at right now and people
are still going out and hanging out with
the buddies because it's not gonna
happen to them so it's like the moment
one of us starts showing symptoms that
person is gonna sleep in the other
bedroom yeah I have my plan to like if I
risk that we're gonna get sick if one of
us gets sick but like at least by doing
that you know it's it's just it helps
mitigate it yeah on top of you know okay
now we know for a fact that we got to
start like sanitizing everything even
harder internally within the home cuz
right now we're in a bit of a safety
bubble at home because we're not going
anywhere yeah you know it's like I
haven't washed my hands in the last hour
because I haven't left my desk in the
last hour right now
speaking of washing their hands that
reminds me one more thing in Iran you
can speak to this if you want to but so
mutation right so generally is the ideas
that you get the disease you can't get
it again well you can get it again if
it's a different mutation of it so
that's why people can still get the flu
year after years because the flu is
mutating it to in order to mutate the
disease has to infect people so if
you're infecting a million people it's a
million chances of mutation if you're
infecting only a thousand people it's
only a thousand chances of mutations so
obviously the more people infected means
the more mutation now if we want to get
a vaccine for this disease we need to
not have it mutate the way to not have
it mutates and not have it infect five
million people before you can develop
the vaccine so once another reason to
stay inside your freaking house don't
interact with other people unless you
have to for some reason to get your food
or whatever like isolate yourselves if
somebody else is in isolating themselves
put pressure on them tell them that they
are doing an irresponsible thing tell
people that they need to be safe you
need to stop socializing with everybody
for a couple weeks here and we need to
get ahead of this curve it's it's just
it's important that we all do our part
and it's not just being isolated it's
also telling your friends to be I said
it's helping to educate people it's
making sure everybody understands that
we are on the cusp of either having
millions dead or come
thousand dead and that is entirely based
on these next couple weeks and how
people act yeah
in the extreme early days of this so
like a week ago when I I was under the
impression that like alright
what if I just get sick now like I could
live and be fine after that
that I'm inoculated I won't get sick
again and obviously I'd still take
precautions not to infect anyone else I
was thinking that would be a good idea
but then I started hearing cases of
people getting sick a second time now
since then I've started hearing kind of
conflicting reports maybe they weren't
getting sick or they were getting
pneumonia instead because their immune
system is trashed after this it's hard
to say but I've also read that
apparently the rate of mutation is not
that fast or COBIT so that's that's a
good thing that's well actually it's an
RNA based virus so it's rated mutation
is a hundred times that of a DNA based
virus so it's still somewhat up there
it's not as fast as influenza but
because it's not influenza and that's
the only thing it's not the flu
everybody talks about it like it's just
a flu it's not the flu but yeah it's
thankfully subset of a flu isn't it I
mean it is I think the flu is also
technically a corona virus I'm not
mistaken yeah but that's just like the
type of like virus I can't speak to that
too closely I'm not you know Jenna so
for those of you that don't know wrens
wife is a nurse she works at a hospital
here in LA so Jenna our question for you
is you know people say like this is just
the flu like is it a flu is it a
relative of the flu what like does this
very resemblance which is like and then
there's this corona virus which is late
everyone's different cuz I thought the
same thing when I first heard about it
I'm like it's just the flu like maybe
the flu on steroids everyone's affected
differently
talked about it how it can be mild
symptoms for some people but the people
who get it bad it's super bad like it's
basically seems to be from what I've
seen in cases like respiratory failure
even in young people
so it can affect your well you can
either develop into pneumonia yeah or it
can affect your it's eating kind of how
people described it yeah that's not good
that's not pneumonia no mo pneumonia is
like what's called alveoli so like these
little like things that help with gas
exchange they look like that gas
exchange occurs and so like when you get
inhale you get your oxygen that's how
it's transferred to your blood is
through those little alveoli okay you
have junk in your lungs that's kind of
hanging out on top of that so that there
gas exchange isn't adequate and that's
why it's like shortness of breath and
coughing so like when people are
coughing with ammonia and stuffs coming
out that's good because it's that junk
that's in their lungs and is preventing
that gas exchange so this isn't a flue
this isn't influenza time you know just
because it's called I don't know if you
guys have seen the charts that are like
these are the symptoms of Corona these
are the symptoms of flu these are its
symptoms of like a common cold and these
are the symptoms allergies so just check
the boxes of like coughing fever
diarrhea's and new ones that's like not
great
[Laughter]
so how was how was the virus related
though like at like the actual like
family level cuz you know like the
Spanish flu h1n1 virus yeah I guess now
we're starting to get like really
technical detail that I know nothing
about the blanket family that it's
instant yeah like the test for it is
called like SARS this was a big deal in
Asia at least you know
years ago it was but it was one of those
things where it's like it wasn't it
didn't seem to be as infectious as it
did like it killed a lot of people but
it didn't infect as many people hmm it's
tough stuff it's thanks for sharing that
information with us yeah thank you
yeah Thank You Jenna so you know with
all that information it's kind of a
gloomy podcast but I think it's
important to put this information out
there and you know what guys let's make
knowledge more viral than the corona
virus gang because they acknowledge more
viral I like it
share share information share knowledge
tell people spread the knowledge faster
than the virus on a lighter note yes
speed on a little graph pulled up here
okay you know you can screen janky all
right these are the these are the top 10
Dow Jones Industrial Average change days
oh yes I've seen the Royal this is today
it's crazy the other dates on there are
all from the late 20s or the there's one
from 87 and then there's there's two
from 2008 so if the economic indicators
are any indication of what we're about
to enter into economically like this is
a clear sign that we are we are in every
session as we speak oh yeah definitely
and we'll get out though that's the
thing we will get out of course it's
yeah no I mean how this the other day on
a piece I was watching and he said
it was a storm but every storm has a
beginning and an end there it is yep if
you're worried about the economy just
know that in this case we know exactly
why the economy is crashing yeah it's
deal with it it'll come back we just
have to make it through that right all
right let's wrap things up on a lighter
note here let's talk about half-life
Alex for a moment Wren and I have been
playing at a whole bunch Christian
watched on he node as we did our first
impressions that video should be out as
you're watching this podcast yes and so
the question was is half-life alex worth
buying virtual reality for rent says yes
we're talking here my barrier to entry
on this was very low I do not have a PC
VR headset even though I take the back I
have the first two dev kits I was like
super like pioneer edge Lord status of
like back in the day 2014 when I got my
headset and then like all the commercial
headsets came out they were expensive
and I never got them I did get a psvr
because it was a cheap option and it
worked with my PlayStation I didn't have
to upgrade my computer but when I picked
up my computer from the studio over the
weekend we have the studio VR headset
that was just sitting there I was like
well I'm gonna borrow this for the time
$10,000 you don't need it so what are
you looking at for computer and headset
setup so now if you have a decent
computer from the last two years should
be fine and VR headsets I don't know
what their availability are I recommend
the rift s because it is the best
quality for the price you'll get but
your if you're wanting to get one like
right now your only option very well
might be the original oculus rift which
is still a good headset slightly higher
quality build than this but you know you
have to set up sensors which is its own
say you don't for the one you have you
don't need sensors you don't need a big
player
basically yeah because the sensors are
built into the headset spot right here
and I was able to just play there's a
few weird complications with it that I
found kind of annoying just because I'm
getting used to modern PC VR but if I
have to give this headset back soon I'm
at a point where like I gotta get a
headset cuz yeah I purchased the game
for myself last night even though I
don't owe the is 399 by the way I mean
right now you're not gonna find your
largest yeah and if you have a computer
that's more than a few years old
probably the best thing to upgrade is
either your RAM or your graphics card or
your hard drive if you don't have an SSD
oh yeah I mean yeah there's there's
literally a list of things that you can
upgrade but you can buy ready built
these for like five hundred six hundred
dollars that are we already I would say
you're talking from scratch you're
talking like a thousand dollars yeah
from total scratch I would say like
what's that but with that you now get an
incredible experience and you get a nice
PC if you have a computer and it's just
okay you probably need to get a new GPU
if it's if your GPU is older than like a
nine eighty or nine seventy then you're
probably need a new GPU but so let's say
two to three hundred bucks for GPU and
four hundred dollars for your VR headset
so let's say you're looking at seven
hundred dollars all in because most
people have a computer so let's just say
you need a new GPU and that's it
Christian if you had to spend $700 to
play half-life Alex would you oh man I
mean yeah that's a hefty price tag
because it's it's super cool I mean
again I've never played half-life or VR
how about just that set just that set
$400 and of course you even be our
headset so you can do other VR said
something then I can go into VR Skyrim
and
works or zombies no oh yeah BC I'm
getting the itch it's coming for sure
after watching me play just see I was I
was definitely waiting on VR to make
sure you know I didn't want to be blocks
and pixels like if I'm gonna go in and
you headset I wanted to be you know
triple a quality and I think watching
half-life yesterday was the first real
viewing I've seen of that level of VR
that's got me interested yeah have live
alex is great if you guys ever get the
chance you can play it it's half-life
straight up really smooth yeah and you
know it feels like I never feels like
they never stopped making games like it
just picks right up like weird the other
half life's left off and it's like
you're right back in the world and like
the art styles there and the environment
and atmosphere is there I was surprised
by the level of detail they put into
their dead bodies faces yeah realistic
looking dead people and they're just
dead bodies lying around yeah well
there's a thing with like it seems like
for a PC game to be truly a classic it
needs to have like a certain type of
gore like PC games have a very special
type of gore like quake had it doom had
it half-life had it you know it's like
that weird low-res like painted gore
that's like way over the top on
characters like and they've brought that
back for half-life Alex it's the weird
over-the-top PC graphics Gore it's like
you know spines fall out the guys and
they blow up it's just it's great it's
wonderful yeah yeah I have been playing
doom eternal and gory heavy and it's so
good I do maternal is wonderful what a
good game yeah
last thing guys if you are in the webcam
mark good on you because I don't know if
you've tried to buy a webcam they are
all out everyone bought every single one
of them
left on the internet everywhere I I
searched for two days to try to find a
webcam before I eventually got in my
truck and drove the studio of God
another one this morning because yeah
what the heck's wrong with you yeah yeah
I mean Amazon Prime's on a delay I mean
all things definitely changed yep so
yeah I think we should change businesses
and games yeah all right well guys it's
a good podcast I know it's a bit of a
downer one but the whole idea is over on
this now
they don't won't be a downer in the
future and we can make some good things
happen so do your part be a good human
being
help encourage others to do the same
just share the knowledge we promise that
everything we talk about in the podcast
is gonna be this in fact we want to make
a point of releasing entertainment for
you guys
throughout this quarantine to help you
stay isolated and have a good time while
doing so so pick up a cool hobby maybe
learn an instrument we'll keep making
some cool videos for all of you and
we'll see you guys in the next podcast
[Laughter]
so long everybody